good morning millennials welcome back to
the toast and happy Tuesday hope
everyone's having a fabulous day
speaking of fabulous hey Jax how are you
doing I'm doing good thank you so much
so excited to be here on this Tuesday to
be joined by you and to just you know
get the week off and running yesterday
was the longest Monday ever I was
looking at Olivia's story and she was
like she posted something like Monday
night dinner and I literally was writing
back Liv it's Tuesday and I was thinking
I was the clown I was the fool
it's it's also really like kind of an
important thing to acknowledge when
you're wrong it's really hard to do but
it's so important so important for sure
but let the record show I did not send
the message because I double checked
with my head no I feel like you and I
were having that conversation yesterday
about like being wrong you know it
happens I'm not sure exactly what you're
talking about when were we talking about
that we're on FaceTime and I was
obviously wrong about something and I
said like obviously it doesn't happen a
lot but you know I can't be wrong and
it's so important to acknowledge when
you're wrong just own it okay yes it's
coming back to me what were you wrong
about
see that's a thing you're the memory
girl here not me so I'm not entirely
sure I'm sure it was something moronic
and inconsequential but nevertheless I
was wrong yeah and you took ownership
and we're so proud of you for that and
that's all we can ask from our girl
growth growth what an ugly word
I love that it's literally heinous Grove
and then wait like growth is obviously
like a beautiful thing you want people
to constantly be evolving but it also
can be like a lesion like you have a
growth on your face here's the thing
growth as a verb greater than growth as
a noun
I completely agree I'm glad that we've
settled that today
um so first episode in La down pat back
for number two hope everyone enjoyed the
kind of change in scenery a lot of
people are saying like this glowy light
behind me is like kind of stunning in
that maybe we should like have that back
at our house get some glowy lights yeah
get the brand name order from Amazon you
know I'll just rip it off the wall and
throw it in my suitcase perfect how are
you liking your time in Los Angeles how
are the Los Angeles treating you
well I haven't really honestly
um interacted with that many Los Angeles
except for the lovely people who work at
your media who have been just so helpful
and so kind and so welcoming because I'm
kind of like I work here now I was here
literally from like nine to five
yesterday I was like the first one in
this morning because we record so early
I'm kind of like the president of this
company are you first one in last one
out
kind of and one thing about me is I
never thought I would be that girl
because I'm like definitely the last one
in first one out kind of Vibes but
that's what happens when you have a
business that you're passionate about
you would know what it's like to run a
business and be the first one and last
one out
but you don't but you don't
so it's been great honestly just like so
productive yesterday I came back
um we did the toast and then I came back
here because Ben and Josh were recording
with some like premium guests like lots
of Comedians and I just kind of wanted
to like see what was going on and then
we all went out for dinner I went to
catch like classic in Florida did you
get paparazzi
I didn't but the last time I was at
catch thank you for bringing that up I
was paparazzied and then I spent the
rest of the evening and the rest of the
weekend looking for the paparazzi
pictures online and they were never
uploaded because I'm sure they were like
oh we took a picture of the wrong girl
no there was footage right they got a
video nothing came of it no no nothing
came of it I was TMZ they were asking me
about Cuba Jr the incident and I was
like more than happy to discuss with
them here was my line
I'm very much looking forward to Justice
being served yeah as she got in her car
and sped away and wait no yeah like this
is like a book as she slinked into her
SUV and drove down Mulholland
and then got into a bath that simmered
and burned her skin
[Laughter]
we were at catch like three years why is
it got a bird why is it gonna burn
though when we were at catch like three
years ago it was during that whole cubic
Junior thing and they when we were at um
all right let's not lie we had
um called I'll take responsibility I had
called I just want to say tmzino and no
point did we lie we just omitted that
like we never said you never said they
recognized me they were climbing for me
you said like I had an interaction with
Paparazzi and that and by the way if you
know anything about the biz you would
know that Claudia called because that's
the only way they show up no I'm so
sorry I was about to lie and be like
Tims he was waiting for me outside no
[ __ ] like well they were and my
publicist because you called them
yeah my publicist at the time I was like
I feel like I want to talk to TMZ and
she was like sure let me arrange that
and nevertheless they were there and so
we were walking out of the restaurant
and he was like Claudia can I talk to
you about Cuba getting Junior and I was
like oh okay
um and it was during the time when he
was on trial and so I gave his cute
little interview and then some some of
the other Paparazzi saw TMZ talking to
me and they were like oh she must be
someone so she took a bunch of pictures
and they never uploaded any of the
footage and I was like really upset two
things one thankfully we were vlogging
and you can watch the footage on our
patreon Vlog of La week 2019 and two now
thinking back to it and you hearing you
tell the story do you think that you're
publicist at the time kind of just like
hired someone to pretend like they were
TMZ to make you think that she did her
job I'm just gonna assume you're
publicist is she because I've never met
a male publicist and I have it just
that's why it was never on TMZ because
it was a fake actor
that's really definitely interesting
that's a
conspiracy theory I think that's great
Hoops to jump through because like my
publicist would have just said like uh
teams ain't interested in your um
unrecognizable ass and I would have been
like okay cool like I'm like I
understand I'm not the most famous
person in the world so I don't think she
necessarily went through you know all
those Hoops just to like satiate my ego
maybe she did I don't work with her
anymore but maybe I'll shoot her a text
we're on good terms being like hey
girlie
the literal job of a publicist just
satiate your ego
like no actually if you have like a good
working relationship with the publicist
like if I went to a publicist I was like
I have you know I want to be on the
cover of Vogue she wouldn't then be like
well Vogue is so busy they actually just
can't fill you in she'd be like no
you're not big enough for Vogue like
not everyone I think there are
definitely some celebrities whose
relationship with people on their team
is like delusional but I don't like I
don't work like that with people like
tell me the truth like what's going on
okay except you are not super Vogue you
aren't asking for a vote
no but like Vogue
like TMZ is like a very it's beautiful
it's my Vogue yeah but no the thing that
I like about TMZ I used to read it like
every single day is like they would have
stories about the smallest like reality
stars that only I would care about from
like are you the one it's like
there really is no one too small for TMZ
and no one too big like they cover
everything for everyone like if you want
to read about this person great and if
you don't you don't have to read it but
like they really talk to the most random
people
what I like about TMZ is their articles
are so normal and short it's not like
they give you an essay of the history of
the person and their entire family in
the most like moronic facts like just
tell us what's going on and end the
article it's okay the article is just
three paragraphs and other Publications
say we're talking about Selena Gomez so
first it will be like the singer the
actor
the um
who says the who says singer the only
murders actress like they keep trying to
find different ways to describe her
until by the end it's like the former
Alex Russo playing Wizard of Waverly
places like just call her [ __ ] Selena
like we don't need it's so weird how
they can't just be like or even keep
saying like the actress that the actress
the actress
yeah no it's beyond annoying especially
when I'm reading the stories for the
show and it's like uh-huh nobody cares
about like what song she's saying 10
years ago nobody cares nobody cares but
you know what I care about
what I love olives thanks Selena
thanks Selena well to bring my story
full circle I did not get paparazzi last
night which was for the best I have
never packed more incorrectly for a trip
in my entire life I don't know what I'm
gonna be wearing for the rest of the
week like I have like I'm seeing friends
like I have not a single thing to wear
um
so it's for the best because I was
looking turnt last night in like a
sweater that didn't fit me
go to the mall like go shopping like I
could but what are you gonna wear to the
49ers game
I'm so glad you just asked because I was
me and Ben get to San Fran this weekend
like a day before the game so I was just
gonna go to like this the team store and
like get a cute like sweatshirt or
something
um but this company reached out bro
denim it's like the official wear of the
Wags like they make custom hoodies
custom so they were like do you want us
to make you something I was like oh my
God thank you so much yes they're
shipping into my hotel in San Francisco
thank God I'm all set there thank God
thank God maybe get something back up
just in case it doesn't get there but
the idea of you just getting a
sweatshirt from the team store isn't
gonna come no like have you been to
those team stores they're so they have
like such cute stuff I mean it's [ __ ]
expensive but they have like bomber
jackets and like really cool shirts like
I was gonna be so cool oh okay that is
cool
I wasn't gonna get like a t-shirt that
says I love Kyle use check on it
actually why not
yeah right you know maybe I was
well that's cool and exciting glad Los
Angeles is treating you well
yeah it is it definitely is like I could
never see myself living here people
everyone's always asking me that like
would you ever live here no first of all
I'd like to keep the toast like I'm
waking up with a crack of [ __ ]
Dawn just to get these episodes out so
that's not gonna work for me and it's
just not
it's not my vibe I don't know it's not
it's not for me
okay I mean I think it's just too far to
even consider but if it was like where
Boston is bye
bye peeps
yeah I mean you only moved like three
hours away so nobody else can move right
did I say that
no it's true oh my God I was sorry I
know you I was talking about myself
that's okay I'm saying like why I would
why I would never move to Los Angeles
you think I'm gonna try and tell you
what to do that's what it sounded like
and I was like damn something is off
today no I went never I was saying for
me if I met he got it for me
um the way that everyone says live your
life the way that I feel is that Los
Angeles is too far of a place for me to
ever move to though I do love
the few days that I spend there at a
time and perhaps if it was as close as
say Boston I could consider it
I understand because I'm like why the
[ __ ] does Jackie want me to live in
Boston like okay no I understand I
apologize I'll own that one so important
to own when you're wrong I was wrong
okay thank you thank you for that you're
welcome
[Music]
and so we actually have a great show
today we have so many stories because we
have two stories with a lot two
categories with a lot of subsets of
stories
are we going to talk about Harry no
oh
like when you say something I listen
no but like you would have no at this
point you would have to like beg for me
to bring back those stories like you
would have to say Jax I want to talk
about Megan and Harry today
no I don't I honestly just thought like
now it's at the point where it's
unavoidable no I don't want to get
chewed out again I don't enjoy like
getting chewed out for my story choices
so selections I heard you
and unless if you want to talk about
them you're gonna have to let me know at
this point because I'm like on notice
no no I don't I don't I just I honestly
thought you would have just like taken
the Reigns and been like we have to
yep nope
the Embargo stands
the Embargo stands I will say I did see
this morning Harry on the cover of
People magazine and I really
um that shocked me like that's so low
brow it's so up until this point it's
been like such so much quantity of press
but it's still been relatively high
quality like 60 Minutes Good Morning
America
People magazine like my God that's
that's desperate that's low no that's
Queen is rolling over
rolling over like how Prince Harry
should never be on the cover of the same
magazine as like Cody from Sister Wives
you know no and it's like William and
Kate are on the cover of people like not
by choice and like Harry put them on
there yeah yeah like that's cool when
you're on the cover just like they're
talking about you not talking with you
no it was a people exclusive and there's
conspiracies that he um made them
Photoshop some more hair on his head
because he's looking
quite hairy
you know what Harry is looking quite
hairless I agree I feel like we're all
so like bent out over Williams balding
when at the end of the day William has
actually embraced it completely like he
could have gotten plugs he's going to be
fully bald in the next few years he's
owning the [ __ ] out of it people roast
him for it and Harry's over here like
very like thinning out balding he's
younger than William he's gonna be in
the same spot as William in a few years
so let's just all let's all keep that in
mind yeah balding doesn't bother me like
in general especially like for men like
me neither I don't notice it I feel like
people who like call it out are like
mean and agreed I don't care if
William's balding or Harry's balding
like it's not how I see them
no I agree I don't think I think balding
for men like same for women like aging
and like there are things that like
plague women as they get older like I
think a lot of women you know gain
weight during menopause it's like things
that they actively try to avoid and for
men like the one thing is balding and
it's not even that big of a deal yeah
it's like
it's not a big deal but it's like all
those things that you describe for women
like no one would ever discuss those
things who's like not the National
Enquirer you know like no one with like
right right you know Scruples whatever
be like she has more wrinkles today
so it's just so true you need to do it
to men about their baldness
I completely agree and I also don't
think it's that big of a deal like Ben
does have an egghead and it's something
like it's one of his like biggest
insecurities the shape of his head so if
he were ever to be bald like his Egghead
would be like really pronounced and
that's why he fears baldness
um but his dad has like really long
thick hair so I think Ben might be okay
but you could say to Ben like you have a
wonderful shaped head everyone would be
lucky to see it and it's all Beauty
or I I could say this which I would like
to say crack an egg on your head let the
yolk drip down let the yolk drip down
let the yolk crack an egg on your head
let the yolk drip down let the yolk trip
down let the yolk trip down squeeze
oranges on your shoulders let the juice
drip down let the juice drip down let
the juice why were we always doing that
[ __ ] in cam because it gives you the
chills now you've got the now you've got
the now you've got the chin you've got
the chivalries there's nothing better
than the chills nothing a chill train at
camp like we all turn around and give
each other chills and then like we turn
around and give the other person chills
give and receive so
amazing I loved getting chills I hated
giving chills I give my self chills all
the time like when I can't sleep I
noticed it's something I've done since I
was a kid like I'm always like we'll
pick one arm up and give myself chills
and then like try and fall back asleep
but like where did these limericks come
from crack an egg on your head there was
like so many of those things it was all
in Camp like like little handshakes and
it was just these things that everyone
Reese's Pieces seven up mess with me
I'll mess you up it's just traditions
yeah passed down through generations
yeah of campers and counselors also
that's like the toast like where do all
our little jigs come from you know and
then they get passed down to the next
generation of toasters so it's just that
camper spirit
I I really I could not have said it
better myself honestly thank you
thank you so much uh we were just
talking about before you cracked an egg
on Ben's egg-shaped head uh Harry Harry
know what I was gonna say something
about Ben's head
oh yeah sure which is that something's
head there's always hair plugs
right right I've heard that the trip
back from the flights from Turkey to New
York are filled with men with like head
wraps on like they have bandages and
their noses and their teeth and their
heads so there's always turkey yeah
there's always Turkish hair very cheap
it's very cheap it's high quality I know
actually know a few people I'm not gonna
say who but I've known a few people
who've taken the trip to Turkey and come
back looking looking quite handsome
would you say it's top quality fabric
I would say it's top quality fabric
that's actually exactly what I would say
great well speaking of top quality
fabric we have so many Bravo stories
today that I'm like very much into
and we should get into them because this
is going to be a very long episode I
think in total we have like eight or
nine stories
so oh good I might even cut out one I
might do like four big categories
Jackie the toast is a painting and you
are the painter so
yeah I'll see how we're doing I'll see
how we're doing uh without further ado
[Music]
here are the fast five stories that you
need to know could be for I'll let you
know it's also kind of technically eight
or nine
the best five stories that you need to
know that could be actually eight or
nine are brought to you by Perfect bar
your New Year's resolution to eat
healthier should be enjoyable right so
why not snack on something that's
nutritious and delicious this year
perfect bar has you covered with their
lineup of fresh from the fridge protein
bars made with freshly ground nut butter
organic honey and or and 20 organic
superfoods perfect bar has a variety of
products like protein bars and little
snack size bars too that are also good
and good for you you are sure to find
something you love my favorite is the
dark chocolate chip peanut butter with
sea salt perfect bar because honestly
dark chocolate with sea salt is crack I
don't know who invented it but it's
actually crack it's so good and I'm
obsessed
um it's a perfect go-to snack you know
I'm running around here being fabulous
in La meetings meetings meetings podcast
podcast I have two snack size perfect
bars in my purse and they've kept me
full throughout the day so I'm not like
crashing and like getting that hunger
fatigue where I just can't perform my
best also on days where we have eight or
nine stories and these episodes are so
long I actually wish that I brought a
little perfect Bart snack up here
because that's what I need to power me
through the episodes
so the texture of the bars are like a
cookie dough texture it's creamy it's
full of flavor and they're packed with
six grams of protein and 150 calories so
a little bit goes a long way
perfect bar knows that it'll be Love At
First Bite so for a limited time they're
offering you a chance to try their
refrigerated protein bars for free
here's how it works sign up for email or
text and upload a picture of your
receipt from your local grocery store
and they'll reimburse you for the cost
of one bar directly into your venmo or
PayPal account so many of you guys have
um message me that you've done it and
it's been like so fabulous to get like a
free snack so I love that for you it's
not too late to do it yet all you have
to do is go to perfect snacks.com toast
get a free perfect bar today that's
perfect snacks.com toast to get a free
perfect bar today happy snacking you can
grab one after a workout or a quick bite
while you're out holiday shopping and
you can feel good about what you're
snacking on
great thank you so much
you're welcome first story page six is
exclusively revealing uh that Beyonce
planned a collaboration with Britney
Spears but it fell through Beyonce
almost broke the internet again the
music Superstar as Britney Spears to
appear in a new music video but the
collaboration ultimately did not come to
fruition multiple sources tell page six
exclusively it is unclear why the plan
fell through Reps for the singers did
not respond to their requests for
comment I found this story to be like
one extremely random and like
said who like you know what I mean like
where does this come from well
no and it's not like reasons for the
collab falling through are unknown like
they're pretty known like just look at
what's going on and it's like what it's
not like we knew that there was a collab
coming and now it's falling through it's
like just to let us know that something
that we had no idea about actually isn't
happening it's just like [ __ ] weird
but I also think the idea that they
would collab is weird
I think so too I was singing the same
thing like it's a collab that actually
makes no sense like it's if this is all
true let's just operate under that
premise like that's extremely generous
of Beyonce to right to do that with
Brittany but like
I don't think that it's I mean just
never appear in a music video like
that's fine what could happen that's
highly edited it's not like they're
working on a song together performing
together but I just feel like
it feels random it feels random I
Britney's not really working like
Beyonce works at an extremely high level
like
yeah what would they do together
no and I and I have to imagine that
every single person in the industry at
the highest level is wanting to work
with Brittany whether it's singing or
interviews or documentary and
I don't think she's interested I don't
think she is wanting to do any of that
like I think it's nice that to have
everyone interested but she's clearly
her priorities are not
to be famous and and work as much as she
can right now I don't know what her
priorities are but they're bad her
priority is not working it's never going
to be I also feel like we all witness
the free Britney movement like everyone
in the industry wanting to work with her
not Beyonce like the agents and the book
publishers and the TV people like all of
them wanting to work with her is very
much against the spirit of the free
Brittany Movement Like We freed Britney
so that she could like literally do
nothing for the rest of her life and
just like be with her get better a
husband and be with her kids and go to
Hawaii and do whatever she wants like if
we wanted Brittany to be working the way
that she was working then that's what
she was doing before
yeah so there of course is a level of
work where it's like you know you're not
doing a Vegas residence every Vegas
residency every single night versus just
doing nothing in Hawaii for the rest of
your life yeah but I feel like
the free Brittany movement like she just
needs time to herself like a long time
yeah and the discourse on Brittany um
online like has actually really started
to bother me I think like the the
digital movement around Brittany when it
came to her conservatorship was so
powerful and like actually made a
difference and now it's taking like a
really annoying turn people you know
decoding her Instagram you know look at
this it's photoshopped and look at this
she's wearing red and yellow means help
it's so moronic and I think people just
need to get used to the idea that
Britney's deeply unwell she's coming off
of a 10-year period where she was like
put on medication against her will and
it's not like she was put on Advil she
was put on lithium like she's not she is
not well like she's gonna be putting out
[ __ ] that's [ __ ] weird and concerning
because she is mentally unwell so let's
not like decode it and go save her and
show up to her house like Sam is trying
to kill her stop like she's just unwell
like let's just accept that at face
value for what it is yes agreed which is
why she should not have to work and just
be able to whatever dance in her living
room and post these and be weird and
boast these ravings on Instagram
yeah and I also think like
people in the industry like
and I'm not saying this about Beyonce
because like I'm I know a million people
have reached out I'm sure and like
wanted to work with her people need to
let her be like she
the Elton John song was really good
um and it was nice to like have her
singing again but I don't think this is
going to be the beginning of an
illustrious career for uh for this isn't
the second coming of Britney Spears yes
I agree uh and I don't really believe
this Beyonce story but it's just weird
and random
I mean I kind of do believe it because
Beyonce's music videos are like these
long works of art like she has so many
like random people in it
so I could see her being like yeah let's
throw Brittany in there like why not
um I I don't think it probably ever got
to a stage like that it was even
remotely confirmed it was just like an
idea on a whiteboard okay
it never it never left the ideation
phase
right but no now somebody at page six
heard about it and it's like making it
into a thing when it's not yeah agreed
okay well moving on to our next story
which is a subset of stories and it's
oh my gosh oh Savannah pump rules
trailer I know the I the iPad started
playing the Vanderpump Rules teller
which is our first story of the day pump
rules Chiller dropped and it looks
unfucking real there's so much going on
obviously Tom and Katie are getting
divorced they're going through stages of
like you know being great friends and
former partners and then like being at
each other's throats Tom Schwartz and
Raquel did hook up they have footage of
them kissing Raquel's also making out
with garcelle's son sheena's yes
sheena's getting married Lala single
talking about her new life she's crying
about you know things that they people
say that Randall has done it looks so
good I was shocked by how much it had me
in a choke hold plus like Schwartz and
Sandy's is crumbling
yep I'm shook to the Core
I was shook too honestly because
Vanderpump Rules first of all has been
off the air for like two years now who
cares
um but so much weirdly has happened and
I do think it this could be the second
coming of Vanderpump Rules like they've
been you know on this downward spiral
for like two three years but this
trailer sounds very promising and I know
a trailer is like supposed to sound
promising
um so we hold out hope but it does look
very good especially like the Tom and
Raquel that's that's like kind of like a
crazy ass thing crazy ass thing
um I [ __ ] but then it looks like
Raquel's kind of in her season of single
dumb like meeting people so it's not
like they're getting into a relationship
but then she's also kind of having a
mental breakdown and the cast members
are saying that she's not okay so she's
obviously going through something James
has a new girlfriend who's on the scene
but what I also found was interesting is
the new cast photos out and it's usually
like the cast members that you know and
love and like everyone else who's even
spoken one word on the show this cast
photo is just the mains they've really
like trimmed it back so who's Maine uh
let me find the photo I forget who
posted it like it's Charlie main no I
didn't see her and James's girlfriend
now that I think about it actually looks
like Charlie
um maybe Lala posted it this morning no
but right exactly like someone like
Peter's not in the cast photo even
though he always is I think Raquel goes
on a date with Peter in the trailer too
oh my God Peter is just like being kept
on staff to go on a date with someone
every five years
yeah I can't believe he's still single
okay here's the picture Raquel Sheena
Ariana Tom
Sandoval Lisa Tom Schwartz James Lala
Katie
good no bro no you know what I mean like
good so even though he's on the show
there was their wedding is on the show
and he's clearly a character like they
did the opposite of what they always do
which is like putting everyone in that
promo picture and in the that promo
scene and instead they're like these are
the cast members that we're focusing on
good it was too much of an ensemble for
the last few years when they were like
merging this new generation and the old
generation it was like Danica it was
just too many people so the I the
concept of them whittling it down I
think is actually really good and not
everyone's partner needs to be a
full-time cast member Brock James's new
girlfriend like not everyone's boyfriend
needs to be like the star
yes yes I agree just plugging in my
computer charger
sorry sorry my computer charger uh I I
do agree and it also just kind of draws
a Line in the Sand because the last few
years things were really wishy-washy
like are we gonna go with the varsity
team are we gonna go with JD and it's
like they've made a choice and I
personally I love the choice in general
I love when you've made a choice and I
feel as though this was the right choice
so I have like a renewed interest in
yeah the Ender pump rules in a big way
no me too it was the trailer was
definitely trailing it was giving what
it was meant to be given like it was
creating hype I don't know if it'll fall
flat compared to the actual season but
it looks very good and it was a very
good trailer and I think there's a lot
of reasons to be excited about it also
yesterday we literally were talking
about the Randall thing and it sounds
like at the end of the trailer when
Lala's talking about like how she's
freaking out if she doesn't know what
people are accusing Randall love to be
true if she's referring to that if she's
referring to just the infidelity like it
seemed cryptic yeah it did and timely so
the show premieres
when does the show premiere
that's a great question I thought I saw
I don't know hopefully soon I hate long
teasers
me too
um I'm ready for Banner from brawls like
maybe it's because I'm like in my La era
but like it's about you are in your La
era
yeah
uh okay more Bravo news page six is also
reporting that Catherine Dennis has not
been asked back to Southern Charm for
the first time in eight seasons
Catherine has reportedly been fired from
the show after starring on it for eight
seasons A source told the US sun on
Monday that her contract was not root
nude for season nine due to several
no-shows and her behavior towards staff
she said quote I know Bravo didn't offer
her a contract but when you treat people
poorly like she has they finally get
sick of it she doesn't show up on time
or show up at all during filming a lot
as Southern Charm fans will recall her
screen time on the show began declining
after her breakup with Caleb quote she
treats people like they are beneath her
she can't stand anyone doing better or
getting more attention than her okay
this seems like someone with an ax to
grind uh personal videos you don't know
like what Catherine thinks or feels but
as a viewer I can say that I think her
schedule and her timing she's just like
a late person she's someone who like
makes Osment decision she also has two
kids so like sometimes things come up
she can't go to everything I imagine in
that part is frustrating where it's like
we're no longer going to be on Catherine
time
yeah no I could see a world in which she
like doesn't prioritize filming is late
to everything like wastes people time I
could totally see that being the truth
but as far as like she doesn't care
about others and she doesn't want anyone
having more attention than her calm down
first of all if she was really that
awful she wouldn't have been on for
eight seasons like the the that speaks
for itself when there were so many other
times she could have been fired and when
people were calling for her to be fired
she like kind of weathered all those
storms and now she's being fired so I'm
just gonna put that one on ice and two
the idea that she doesn't want people
having more shine than her I've actually
never seen a cast member not want to be
on a show so much like more literally
all Catherines by the way owl Catherine
has to do on the show all she has to do
on the show is show up and she's the
main character like everyone's always
talking about Catherine like
everything's about Catherine and she
actually doesn't even do that and even
when it is about her she doesn't want it
to be about her like she's the only one
only female who's been on for since the
beginning and like she doesn't even ask
act like she's the OG like she it's like
she doesn't like the attention
this article is contradictory because
those two things cannot be true she
never films but she doesn't want other
people to be uh more airtime than her
well how can that be true right if she
wanted all the attention she would never
miss a cash trip she would never miss a
dinner she would never miss a drink show
up to everything early right but that's
not her she just is herself and people
are interested in her and like gravity
towards her and she's just someone who
like
some people as you said I just are the
main character the thing is she's not
always the main character because she's
not always present
right I don't know if I feel like she's
like definitely like always the main
character I feel like at one point she
definitely was I found a lot of her
behavior last season to be like truly
abysmal I mean it makes for great
television but I can imagine she's
definitely could be nightmarish to work
with yeah I should I think everyone
could could see that but I think there's
also a really soft side of her because
people it's on the show like they do
really love her she's had these
friendships for a long time they care
about her and like Craig who's always
our barometer for who's good and who's
bad like he loves Catherine and I feel
like she's just trying her best
no and that's all we can expect ask from
people honestly so this [ __ ] who gave
all the quotes to the son also continue
to say sounds like somebody who like had
beef with her in Middle School like
holding on to such a grudge and like a
personal Vendetta it sounds personal
they went on to claim that Bravo even
brought in a new producer to quote
handle her behavior quit I know she's
had money issues and now I don't know
how she's going to work she's never had
a job I'm worried for her but maybe this
is a wake-up call
Jesus Christ like calm down honestly
like I'm surprised this person in order
to like sound believable didn't scale
back a little bit on what's clearly like
a very personal gripe they have with
Catherine I would also say like being on
the show for eight seasons is a job
so she's had at least one say the same
and never forget when she worked at that
department store true Gwen's gweneveres
yeah
you know
at Brian's house in um
in Pennsylvania in the Attic there is a
ghost like the woman who lived there the
house is like from the 1700s and the
woman who lived there in the 1700s and
who died in the Attic her name was
Guinevere
R.I.P rip
all right rip Guinevere rip Guinevere
and again I'm with all of these stories
today I'm just like I don't necessarily
believe the veracity but yeah I'm taking
it you know I'm just gonna go along with
the media narrative skepticism and I'll
say that if this is true I will I will
be missing Catherine on the show
especially because it's always sad when
a Show's been on for a long time and
then an OBG goes because at this point
only Shep and Craig will be OG's left
right I do think that the similar
similarly to Van imprint rules this
really is an ensemble cast and I don't
think one person leaving can really make
or break it and if there was I don't
think that person is Catherine I really
think southern charm is special in the
way that like there's not one major star
like I feel like for Vanderpump Rules
for a while it was like the Stasi show
so like her leaving like definitely
impacted the show in a major way and I
feel like with Southern Charm like they
really all are everyone has a favorite
there's not like one person maybe for a
while it was Shep but like everything
comes and goes and it Ebbs in his flows
and I don't think one even an OG leaving
would really impact the show that much
no not at all and every season it's a
new
story that we're focused on like a new
couple I don't even know what it's going
to be next season it might be Taylor
Shep's ex who's you know now single and
right and the whole country is rooting
for her
yeah and Tom Schwartz and Tom Schwartz
who she said she wanted to be set up
with
right
okay great are you ready for our next
story
yes is this third story third Bravo
story so we're still in the Second Story
we're still in the second subset well if
I may just to very quickly tell you that
the Bravo subset is brought to you by
kitch they say that hair care is the new
skin care but there is one brand that
has taken it to the next level and
that's Kitsch a cult-like following
they've created game-changing Essentials
that beauty enthusiasts swear by from
satin pillowcases to time saving towels
kitchen knows that hair care doesn't
stop in the shower they offer
game-changing time-saving Beauty
Essentials for Hair Skin and Body
whatever your budget your skin type your
hair type kids believes that you deserve
little indulgences at affordable prices
morning noon and night they were started
in 2010 and they started selling their
hair ties door to door just a hustle and
a dream they are now self-funded female
founded and carried in over 20 000
retail locations
kitch's best sellers include satin
pillowcases caps and eye masks so the
satin is vegan it's cruelty free and
it's so good for your hair if you're not
sleeping with like satin accessories you
will wake up with A Rat's Nest that took
me way too long to understand and now
that I'm at a hotel and like I don't
have my products with me my hair is
actually crazy I have to do like a full
blowout in the morning whereas if I just
go to bed with a satin pillowcase I wake
up with like fresh hair that I just have
to like comb they also offer shampoo and
conditioner bars part of bottle-free
beauty they have heatless satin curling
rollers so you can say goodbye to heat
damage they are Tick-Tock videos of
people throwing away their 600 curlers
for this don't forget their classic hair
ties and scrunchies kitch is offering
you 30 off your entire order when you go
to mykitch.com toast that's right 30 off
anything and everything at my kitch my
k-i-t-s-c-h.com slash toast so one more
time that's mykitch.com toast for 30 of
off your order start taking care of your
hair because your hair is the frame of
the face and if like me it's also the
security blanket of your face you're
going to want to take good care of it so
that it's around for years to come and
you don't have to take a trip to Turkey
catch greater than turkey turkey
message of today's lesson
are you ready for our next story which
is just story two subset three
yes Real Housewives ultimate girls trip
season forecast announced they are going
to Marrakech and here who is joining
that wasn't English
Caroline man is joining
Caroline Manzo Real Housewives of New
Jersey Alex McCord of real housewives in
New York City
pause pause I
cannot put into words whoever was
responsible for this has my undying love
and devotion not only that Alex McCord
is making a return to the franchise but
that she's going to Morocco where she
was accused of being a buffalo coming
down the stairs
so next level iconic even Louis Vuitton
makes mistakes I I have not been excited
about something in Housewives like in
the realm of the housewives for many
many months and Alex McCord is out here
reinvigorating my spirit I love this
queen Johann and Francois mom I recently
rewatched the first couple of seasons of
Beverly of New York Housewives during
the pandemic and I have to say like the
way we were so mean to Alex McCord
simply because she lived in Brooklyn
like I stand this queen till the day I
die and now she's living her best life
being a psychologist in Australia and I
cannot wait to see that [ __ ] in Morocco
yeah I feel like everyone who's on the
cast and there are some big names here
that I will read I think everyone who's
joining thinks that they are the biggest
name some of them could make the
argument for themselves but without
question Alex McCord being on this is
the biggest get for peacock period yep
period and obscurry a gerd Eva Marcel
and Phaedra Parks from Real Housewives
of Atlanta
Brandi Glanville and Camille Grammer
from Real Housewives of Beverly Hills
and Vicki gumbelson and Gretchen Rossi
from Real Housewives of Orange County
okay now correct me if I'm wrong because
I only watched five minutes yes Dreadful
Berkshires Eva Phaedra Brandy and Vicki
were all in the Berkshires and now
they're doing another season of girls
trip
thank you I mean if I got cast on
Ultimate girls trip and I had to go to
Massachusetts and other women were going
to like Thailand and Morocco and Turks
and Caicos like I'd be pissed too so I'm
glad they're getting a second chance
because it ain't Fair
um but life isn't fair so I'm glad
they're getting a second chance but I
was confused I'm like why does it sound
like a hella repetitive yeah I mean
maybe they performed well on that season
you know what's so crazy it's like the
Thailand the Thailand one I didn't hear
a thing about it like I think it aired
already did it no oh no okay so maybe
that's why I haven't heard about it wait
no I feel like it was announced so long
ago like it has to have already come out
no that's an amazing question because
why would they announce season four
right season three no way did it come
out and we heard nothing about it
maybe I'm wrong I'm probably wrong it
didn't come out okay I'm wrong
so important you're wrong thank God I
was like oh my god um so important to
acknowledge when you're wrong Jax okay
but they filmed that so long ago I feel
like I've seen so many pictures of like
Heather gay in Thailand and yeah when
does it come out
I don't know that's an amazing question
and I hate to announce season four when
season three hasn't even come out yet
right like do you guys deserve a season
four even
by the way yeah you're making me think
like maybe at dinner no no I feel like
it definitely didn't because I look at
page six every day and like even when
the Berkshire was was happening and I
wasn't watching like I saw headlines
it's scheduled to Premiere in 2023. okay
so it didn't come out yet
no it did not come out yet but I will
say I did think it was weird now that
I'm thinking about it maybe I don't that
like four of these women have already
been on a show together but it's kind of
nice that like there's history because
it's like you you don't know each other
got a whole lot of history
okay it goes like this oh God
May got a whole lot of history
we can be the greatest team
that the world has ever seen you and Meg
I love that song Thank you for bringing
that back to our attention and yes it
adds another layer it's a group of women
who like know who don't know each other
and some of them who do that's the
importance of History
history 101 importance
of history is incredibly relationships
no is incredibly important period 100
that's such a such a valuable thing
you've just said
yeah I think and people don't realize it
they're all about the future they're all
about thinking about the future
now we actually sound like one of those
like inspirational podcasts that like
actually don't say something okay don't
have any actual meaning let's do a bit
that we can make into a reel that would
be like one of those podcasts not like
for our reels but just so that like then
people think oh maybe this is a podcast
I could go to to get some of that
nonsense you know okay okay hold on
so I feel like it's really important to
always be intentional with what you do
because once you feel like super
intentional and
um intentive with your body it it'll
change your life like I've noticed a
visible shift in my intentions that's so
true that you said that and I feel like
for me when I want to set intentions
it's so important to look to the Past in
order to see the future and you can see
the future through the lens of the past
and what we've been given in the present
is a gift
that wow I'm actually like I'm getting
emotional because when I went through my
journey I discovered that too you know
how how important the past is but also
not to forget about the present and of
course you know the future can really
help you be intentional but without that
understanding of the past and the
present we have no future and the
children have the future
and you know what I believe I believe
the children are our future teach them
well and let them lead the way yeah
Jenna Maroney like whenever I sing that
song I feel like Jenna Maroney who sings
that song
Jenna Maroney right okay so it makes
sense that you think like that okay I
think when we post that real like we're
gonna get so many new listeners
yeah who are going to come to this
podcast looking for like intentional
wellness and they're gonna find like two
[ __ ] brain dead morons being like
rice and Stripes no but
but that's a podcast that sounds like a
real podcast podcast no like sometimes
I'll see clips of like people who do
like really like intent like I don't
even know what the genre is who just do
like podcasts about like non says jargon
nonsense podcast jargon npj
this is a sentence that's not sentencing
like it makes not one iota of sense yeah
that to me people will comment and be
like so true what no that's one of my
biggest pet peeves in life are people
and maybe that's why I wasn't cut out
for the corporate world people who say
sentences that don't say anything and
maybe like they say a paragraph and
within that paragraph there's like one
thing I can thread through but like
every sentence matters
um I completely agree
so that's who's on Real Housewives
ultimate girls trip season four
it sounds good mostly because of Alex
McCord honestly the rest are just like
sure great I mean Camille grammar is
kind of a great get too the rest are
supporting characters to Alex McCord's
main character energy I agree Camille
Grammer Camille grammar would have been
the main character of this season if not
for Alex McCord signing up
and I'm actually really looking forward
to like seeing what Alex McCord is like
I think we definitely caught her at a
unique time in her life I know like her
kids are grown now she's like much she's
like gotten her education she's probably
really different because she was like so
[ __ ] desperate on the early days of
New York like could not get arrested
just wanted to be invited places and it
was like the one thing people would not
give her was an invitation mostly
because she lived in Brooklyn so I would
like to see like how she's matured
100 100
are you ready for our next story
yeah which is a bit of cancer cancel
culture news because Chris Harrison
is this what you thought I was gonna say
no no I was just ready I'm preparing
myself for like a hot take on cancer no
no you could sit down like it's it's
just about Chris Harrison is launching
launched his podcast podcast called the
most dramatic podcast ever with Chris
Harrison and he dropped the first two
episodes and honestly from what I've
seen he's spilling the tea he talks
about how he lost 20 pounds and was
scared to death amid the bachelor
controversy Fallout so I'm gonna read
all the details some of the quotes that
he shared because like he's naming some
names he's speaking out for the first
time about the controversy that led to
his abrupt exit from Bachelor Nation he
said quote I was heartbroken I was
gutted I was embarrassed I was mad at
myself I was disappointed in myself the
last thing in the world I would ever
want to do was to be an agent of
anything negative whether it had to do
with race or anything
he also revealed the personal toll that
the controversy took on him after
Decades of hosting the ABC franchise
quote things but out of control for a
number of reasons and I was sick sick to
my stomach I lost 20 pounds I didn't
sleep I didn't eat I was scared to death
it was just one gut punch after the
other and mentally and physically I
deteriorated pretty bad he admitted that
during the interview he was not his
normal eloquent self quote I didn't
express myself like I normally do I
think that part we all agree on but as
far as my standing in the community in
the show it didn't it really didn't
register on the Richter Scale there were
so many more egregious things going on
in the world and things that had
happened he said though that his apology
was warranted because he did misstep and
he did make a mistake he said during the
Fallout he recalled certain cast members
campaigning to take over his hosting
duties he said that uh Nick vile no
doubt wanted to take his job this is
what he said quote Nick wasn't really
strongly against me or said anything but
I think Nick was one of those among many
who probably saw the blood in the water
he saw saw the opportunity of a job that
would be really phenomenal and no doubt
he wanted that job
he noted that in addition to Nick there
were plenty of other stars from the
franchise who seemingly used his exit
for their benefit he said quote it
helped them with their 15 minutes of
fame he was definitely not shocked by
their behavior he said it's the people
that you would expect I knew about
certain cast members that were calling
in it was hilarious and the funny thing
is the people that were calling in like
asking for the job he said quote I knew
had had no chance to get the job
meanwhile other Bachelor Nation Stars
including Sean and Catherine Lowe Lauren
and Ari leindyk Andy Dorfman and Ben
Higgins reached out to Chris privately
and showed their support for him
following the controversial exit he also
specifically applauded Wells Adams as
being one of the first to reach out
however he told Chris at the time that
he was going to stay out of the drama
due to his recurring bartending gig on
Bachelor in Paradise and his future
within the franchise Chris said I
appreciated him because if anybody had
sites on the job it was easily Wells and
deservedly so by the the way I thought
to be completely candid that Wells was
going to get the job I thought it was
the easiest call he's in the family
everybody loves him it just seemed like
a layup the wells did not get the job
Jesse Palmer got it Jesse Palmer wow
okay it's just funny how like for so
long you know Chris Harrison was above
all this like he had the greatest job in
the world there was so much infighting
within Bachelor Nation like drama and he
was never a part of it he had the best
job he'd show up for an hour go home and
make a million dollars now he's just
like the rest of us getting on podcasts
dropping names I find a Nick vile thing
to be the most interesting
um and it's clear there's there's beef
there I don't even remember Nick bile
being so vocal during that Scandal Chris
didn't say he was vocal Chris said if
actually he wasn't vocal at all but like
he said no doubt that Nick was kind of
like positioning himself for the job
probably in not being vocal and not like
taking a hard stance and just like yeah
positioning himself as a good choice for
it and he would have been as far of the
people in Bachelor Nation who are
Talking Heads he would definitely be on
the short list right there with Wells
because he is a professional commentator
now
and did Chris say anything about his
standing with Rachel not in the the
quotes that I saw but it is a two
episode Rachel Lindsay and Rachel
kirkanel
it's a two episode podcast it could be
in there I didn't listen to the episodes
these were some of the poll quotes that
made it out but you know and maybe
that's just the juiciest parts of it but
I don't know two episodes and you're
finally mentioning it all I would
imagine that there's more Within These
episodes that's worth listening to
I agree if you really care like I'm so
out of Bachelor world like I find this
juicy but not enough to like care and
sit down and listen
um I I feel like even before the Chris
Harrison thing the the show was on its
way down and then that whole Scandal
just really kind of some like spiraled
it even further into Oblivion yeah I
would say that that was the beginning
that was the end
I don't think it was the beginning of
the end I think it had already begun and
then that was really like the nail in
the coffin yeah oh my God I saw a
headline the other day naming the new
Bachelor and it was the first time that
I didn't recognize the name the face the
person anything like because usually
it's like someone from the previous
season who I've been seeing in headlines
so I'm like okay yeah Gabby Rachel uh I
never saw this man in my life or heard
of his name it's it's so crazy there was
a time when it was the biggest show when
even just being associated with it would
make you you know give you a career it
was so powerful
and it felt like it would be that way
forever yeah but nothing lasts forever
mclared
no but I thought the bachelor would
honestly yeah well so now I wonder what
his angle on podcasting is going to be I
really don't think he can like be
sitting down with Bachelor people I
think that would be a major step down to
go from like being the king of Bachelor
Nation to you know just another court
jester
but like why would his podcast title
reference the show like well I think
it's just like it's visibility for him
and and he could turn it to be having
dramatic interviews with I don't know uh
a horse race owners because like he used
to do broadcasting for horse races yeah
that's what he did before The Bachelor
literally I thought you were gonna say
he could have sit-down interviews with
[ __ ]
that too and that would also be an
extremely dramatic podcast
that would be you know I guess it could
just be like a dramatic interview series
it's not always going to be about the
bachelor but he needs to find an angle
he can't just be like a podcaster who
commentates on pop culture because like
at one point he was pop culture like but
I think he is a very good
interviewer talking head broadcasting he
needs to find what his thing is maybe
Chris Harrison has like interests and
maybe he'll be you know the number one
like fishing podcast where it's like
very dramatic talking about like all
these different catches
no I could definitely see it becoming a
podcast about fishing that's an amazing
point so I think he really needs to do a
180 and find a niche for himself
me too but I also appreciate him taking
the first two episodes so like let's
talk about the elephant in the room of
course what's going on give us the tea
but then maybe now we're going to do a
podcast about elephants and what's going
on in the elephant community
I mean if you haven't seen the
documentary an apology to elephants like
please it's it's less than an hour it's
so short and it's the best documentary
on the planet it could become some sort
of True Crime interview podcast where he
talks to victims of crime
perhaps it could be anything the world
is his oyster it could become a podcast
where I feel like people have tried to
do this but I can't think of one that's
one out where he talks to cancel people
that actually would be an interesting
podcast I would love to be on the
episode yeah I think that someone should
do that podcast
yeah that's actually a really good call
like you just go through their whole
Scandal and like break it down yeah
who simply cancel people but then there
would be other better titles for that
podcast but I guess it would again be a
dramatic podcast
yeah yeah no that's good the
possibilities are endless for Chris
we're wishing him well in the podcasting
sphere you know we enjoy it here we hope
you like it here welcome
welcome welcome welcome welcome welcome
welcome welcome welcome welcome welcome
welcome
to the podcast sphere
are you ready for our next story
yeah
should it be our final
um tell me the last two stories and I'll
tell you if we should just choose one or
both one or four Ashley Simpson Ross
talks the nerve-wracking moment she
played music for her mother-in-law Diana
Ross
okay right it's like could go what's the
Fifth Fifth Gwyneth Paltrow recalls the
wild 90s party scene and how she was
doing cocaine and not getting caught
that one skip to it for sure when is
Paltrow joining James Corden on The Late
Late Show with James Corden and she
admitted there was a time when she
wasn't such a health and wellness Guru
like she is now and she was surrounded
by such unhealthy influences
she was on the show promoting her
four-part audible series The Pursuit
while this year's Golden Globe not a
mini Hillary Swank was discussing Alaska
Daily
Corden said you both came up in the 90s
which is having quite the Renaissance at
the moment the fashion the music what
was it like for what was it like for
both of you being so famous at a time
when there was no social media no
nothing what do you remember about that
time she said Gwyneth it was great I
mean talk about doing cocaine and not
getting caught like you could just be at
a bar and be like having fun dance on a
table you could no camera phones
especially in New York interestingly
enough there were no Paparazzi you could
stumble out of a bar and go home with
some Rando and no one would know
hmm well honestly I do often think about
how like
being famous is obviously great I do
think this is like the worst time ever
to be famous like there's really never
been more of like a lack of privacy for
people and like because of phones and
everything but also people
celebrity culture has gotten so [ __ ]
that people have no boundaries anymore
like people have really lost their
marbles so I do often think about how
like back in the day like Judy Garland
she like left her house four times a
year and like was rolling like raking in
the dough but I also think like before
the cell phones and then kind of in like
maybe like the flip phone era very much
like early 90s I think that was probably
like the most iconic time to be famous
yeah but I also feel like even though
celebrities don't have privacy these
days they they have a way of doing their
thing and you know I don't you don't see
a video every day of a celebrity doing
cocaine but like celebrities do cocaine
no for sure for sure no there's a way to
do cocaine and not get caught I
completely agree but what I'm saying I'm
not talking about just cocaine I'm
talking about like just celebrity life
and right now like I think our culture
is probably the most it's ever been
obsessed with celebrities and like
I don't know it kind of it kind of sucks
yeah it does and I also think you know
us the way that we engage with
celebrities it makes the whole
experience like more transient and your
time is up even faster there's someone
new who's going to come out but yeah
it's like anything else there's pros and
cons so that would be a con of like
internet culture but a pro is that
anybody can get famous and like even
though people who have the resources and
the access have a leg up everyone has
you know access to YouTube like Justin
Bieber is famous because of YouTube like
no you're 100 right there's definitely
pros and cons I think another Pro of
like the digital space while it is so
toxic is there's so much money to be
made so many celebrities who don't even
like do like they they make more money
on their like moronic Instagrams than
they do from like acting right
right no totally there's definitely
benefits but I I think maybe it's
because it's in the past and you'd look
back on things fondly and like through a
nostalgic lens but it does feel like
being famous in the 90s was probably so
much more fun
oh for sure I mean the 90s were just fun
we were like five and six but we were
having a ball
yeah no but like now when you look back
on that like those like the club era and
it really everyone was like just doing
drugs like it looks fun yeah but you
also had like enough technology to make
your life simpler like you had a cell
phone but it just made calls you know
but you could communicate with the next
person where's the next party but it
doesn't you know also
hold your hand while you're taking your
[ __ ] like and wipe your ass for you a
hundred percent exactly like I and
that's what Gwyneth was saying and she
really like her like like old photos
when you look back on them like it's
just so iconic yeah also it's like you
could call up for delivery and get
delivery to your door but you didn't
have ubereats where it's like two
seconds so simple
no so you really have like the same like
accessibility to stuff but just not the
same like level of accessibility yeah
which is too much accessibility
I agree no it does feel like to be like
an actual like major celebrity these
days like I I do feel like there's
probably a lot of parts of it that are
extremely annoying like the lack of
privacy the way like you're like fan
culture has become so toxic and so
invasive and a lot of that has to do
with the internet I think there's like a
lot of things about being famous in in
this day and age that like stink yeah it
reminds me did you see that video of Bad
Bunny where he was with a fan like a fan
was like following him not following him
just like walking phone walking with his
Entourage in Dominican Republic and then
she comes up to him shoves her her phone
in his face to like take a selfie or
FaceTime whatever and he grabbed it and
he chucked it
I loved every minute of that like people
deserve privacy people deserve personal
space and if you're not gonna respect
that [ __ ] around and find out and she
did she literally she found her phone in
the bush yes she found her phone in the
budget now she can tell everyone that
bad bunny through my phone there you got
your story
I was obsessed with that moment like no
yeah fans we you should respect your
fans they gave you your career yada yada
people deserve personal space and if you
can't respect that your phone's going in
the bush yeah I totally agree it's not
like she's at a meet and greet like
yeah no he's literally just walking like
a human being like the way we've just
put these celebrities on a pedestal to
the point where they're not human beings
anymore and we feel like we can grab
them and touch them inappropriately like
it's beyond we are not okay no no but
that as always is the takeaway from
every episode of the toast people are
not okay and as long as you keep that in
mind I think you'll do well in this life
I really do and just you know know that
and try not to be a part of the problem
as best as you can and then the more
people who listen to the toast the less
people who are part of the problem hence
World Peace
by the way just following about a story
from yesterday about the dogs and the
frogs the dogs won and it apparently
like they won by like 50 points and all
these people who flew to LA to see their
Texas Christian University Frogs play
like kind of wasted their time yeah well
I'm sure it was exciting they were
called like the horny toaded frogs or
something like that the toast something
the corn frog and frogs yeah [ __ ]
weird
um I'm sure I don't I've never heard of
TCU in the horned frog so I imagine that
they are not in the national
championships often so it was probably
like exciting to just go to a
championship yeah uh even though they
[ __ ] wipe the court with you
um yeah they what the dogs wipe the
floor with the frogs and
um I live in New York you know what
should have been the theme song of the
national champion ship do tell you ain't
nothing but a dog
get it
frog player I get it I completely agree
so that's just a free marketing idea for
the next time TCU goes up against
Georgia dogs
wishing well to all of our Tennessee
Central University students and fans but
I'm happy for you guys that you made it
to the championship like imagine if
Colgate me to the championship you
wouldn't see me complaining that we
didn't win right it's not about the
destination it's about the journey yeah
it brought the community together it was
very exciting for all of you and you
should be grateful
it's centralized the Tennessee Central
University Community yeah because people
don't know about Tennessee Central you
think it would be in like Central
Tennessee but it's not right
right you'd think it would be centrally
Tennessean but it's pretty like it's
kind of borders the Border
yeah yeah it's kind of like not Central
[Laughter]
I think that's our cue to end this
episode
oh without further Ado thank you so much
for listening to the toast the
millennial Morning Show where we deliver
the fast five stories that you need to
know everybody through Friday on YouTube
so if you're watching this on YouTube
please feel free to subscribe and give
this video a thumbs up we're also
available as a podcast anywhere podcast
can be found so at Spotify iTunes
citrary public video I have radiocast
box all the places whoever you listen to
podcasts find us the toes leave a
five-star review about how wickedly
talented and centrally Tennessee and we
are hope you guys have
Tuesday and we'll see you tomorrow for
hump day love you guys bye love you bye